concerts de klaxons samedi au rond-point
de la résistance aux clayes-sous-bois à
l'appel d'une dizaine de gilet jaune
un huitième acte pacifique pour montrer
au gouvernement qu'ils sont toujours
aussi déterminés nous
voulons en fait tout simplement nous
mouvements des gilet jaune des claies et
alentour mobiliser le maximum faire des
opérations forte pour que la france
puisse entendre qu'il ya aussi un
mobilisation n'y a pas seulement qu'à
part et il ya aussi en région dont dans
les yvelines
balla au sommet sur une voie pour
bloquer un petit peu la circulation pour
pouvoir dire aux gens qu'on est là quand
je rate toujours là et que qui vous faut
qu'ils s'assurent qu'ils viennent nous
rejoindre
les manifestants ont également rendu
hommage aux personnes blessées ou
décédées depuis le début de la
mobilisation actions moins solennelle en
ce week-end de l'épiphanie une
distribution de galettes des rois
étaient organisées auprès des
automobilistes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça n'est pas allé jusqu'au justement
parce qu'il y en a qui veulent durcir
c'est ce qu'il ne faudrait pas faire
mais oui je pense que ça va amener à
quelque chose
j'espère en tout cas s'il faut être là
tous les samedis au mois de janvier
février mars aux listes alors que le
grand débat national doit s'ouvrir dans
les prochains jours les gilet jaune des
clayes-sous-bois semblent déterminés à
poursuivre leur mobilisation
toujours dans la convivialité